innovation is a lot of things it's in
the classical pathway of research it's
in the
um
implementation of new technologies into
your work
um it is
intrapreneurship in other words
innovation in the
organizational process in the way that
things work maybe in the technology that
you use and things become more digital
and the part that i
focus on is the invention of new things
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about innovation in healthcare
meet leore perol founder and director of
the rabin medical innovation center and
senior cardiologist he also serves as
the medical director of victorious
medical technologies and as the chairman
of powerful medical as a scientific
board before these roles leo completed
his fellowships in interventional
cardiology and the biodesign innovation
program at stanford university lior is a
dedicated physician who complements his
work with research and innovation
striving to identify global medical
needs and implement solutions for these
within the vibrant israeli ecosystem
leopel welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
thank you thanks for having me i'm great
how are you
i'm great thank you so much for being
here i'm really excited for us to have
this conversation over the next 20
minutes you are the chief innovation
officer of the rabine medical center at
klalit health services uh i i love
talking about healthcare i love talking
about technology i love talking about
the innovation that brings
the two together and so leo before we
even get started talking about what you
do today you you're coming with from the
medicine side not from the technological
side tell me a little bit about your
entrance into the medicine world and how
you shifted towards thinking more about
innovation less about the cardiology
sure um well i think i wanted to be a
doctor
as long as i can remember
i
specifically remember drawing a fake
heart to my grandmother uh trying to
prove to her that i understand
cardiology already at the age of six or
seven
and only wow to be by the parents and to
be embarrassed uh i didn't think she'll
show it to them and i know i knew they
knew that i don't know how a heart uh
anyway
this is this was on my mind early on i
later became a paramedic and then i
really saw what things are like in the
military and i decided medicine is
definitely something i want to
take part of in cardiology specifically
interventional cardiologists opportunity
i actually i can take i can take
part of uh by actually
really difference in
in patients who are extreme situations
so that's that's really a privilege
absolutely i think my background goes
back to my parents who were
uh different
from one one from the other uh in
several ways my father was a science
academic background uh that really
influenced me and my
mother
is a brilliant uh creative artist
uh who sees the worlds in colors and
shapes and
sounds and emotions in a way that uh
really affected all of us and i think
that that definitely made a difference
on how i i look at the world myself so
the creativity part was always something
i was i was drawn to um
and then during my training i
uh i took part of several innovative
processes uh you know israel is an
amazing startup uh
uh
state right a
small empire of innovation and
creativity and i i was very fortunate to
come across a few projects had a few
ideas of my own and i discovered how
how impactful nickel startup is in an
innovative process
and uh and i really became in love with
that as well so i decided things when i
did my training in the us i trained in
interventional cardio
in cardiology at stanford and then i
moved on to
to another training program which is
called the biodesign and uh that really
teaches the
way
um you can move propagate innovation
within the medical within the healthcare
system
now i i would love to hear a little bit
of what what it means from an
organizational perspective like khalid
or the robin medical center what does it
mean to even consider innovation in this
space and and then how does that fit
into your role as chief innovation
officer
right that's a great great question i
mean one of the things that um
organizations and and people are asking
themselves um is what is innovation um
what what constitutes innovation look at
the number of innovation
if you do a search on our
medical journals or google scholar and
search for the word innovation and an
exponential growth in the last 10 years
and many of these things are basically
research
academic institutions and so on that
change their names to innovation and how
everything is research and innovation
i think that
innovation innovation is a lot of things
it's in the classical pathway of
research it's in the
implementation of new technologies into
your work
it is
intrapreneurship in other words
innovation in the
organizational process in the way that
things work maybe in the technology that
you use and things become more digital
and the part that i
focus on is the invention of new things
and that sometimes is the hardest thing
to do
so in other words um what they're
focused on is
finding new opportunities for inventions
like large unmet clinical unmet needs
within the
healthcare system and
see if there's an
opportunity to uh we research the need
and we look at the process
we look at the problem and and judge it
from different angles and we try to see
if this is something we can and should
invent
a new technology too
again based on the need itself and not
so much on the technology
uh and then we move on to actually
brainstorming and inventing
so
to me
the epicenter of innovation is the part
that has to do with inventions the part
that i do with finding new technologies
new solutions to large unmet needs
and so within the clelit and the rabbit
medical center
what we focus on is all of these things
but
the the again the the core essence is
the innovation lab which works to
recognize unmet needs
to characterize them um to see the
opportunity to collaborate on finding
new technologies to brainstorm and to
invent
and other than that within the a large
hospital like ours and obviously the
felipe there are other aspects such as
in the assimilation of new technologies
in the collaboration with other
companies who try to research their own
inventions for the first time within our
hospital
and and within research uh specifically
in the big data and ai worlds
there's
it's really a spectrum you start with
research
these large ideas and based on data and
they sometimes translate into
actual solutions
in actual implementation or digital
tools but in many cases they remain
research and that's fine as well so it's
there's a connection between all of
these things
um and at the rabine medical center uh
we we work on all these aspects
and so can you give me a few specific
examples of how then you come as an
integrator and and test out these new
technologies these new opportunities and
and perhaps even one that you know made
an impact whether it's a lead or
something that could potentially make an
impact moving forward
yes absolutely actually last week with
our second uh anniversary of the
innovation lab we
presented six
wonderful projects at the uh uh at the
paris
uh center for peace and innovation
and we've and the thing is we are open
to anyone coming in here specifically
clinicians or employees
whether it be physicians or nurses or
technicians
anyone who recognizes a problem and they
have a burning desire to solve that
problem because they're going to work
for it right
because they they and
will actually um
mentor them and do this process of needs
characterization needs finding
and move on to um to brainstorming and
invention so some party a
resident in training in neurology who
came in with
the the problem of strokes during
surgeries
so a
vascular events as we call our accidents
as we call them in a more scientific
manner but strokes occur in many cases
within the hospital unfortunately
and
it's easy that well it's easier to
diagnose it when it the patient comes in
the family surround them um and
they're wide awake and we can judge if
there are any neurological deficits but
when the patient is undergoing surgery
um under anesthesia
and
there's really no one to talk to
they are at risk of having this event
only to be diagnosed too late two or
three hours later when the patient is
already excavated or breeding by
themselves
and the sedation or the anesthesia is
not
efficient anymore so
this algorithms to look at
a patient and test their
motor or
muscle
reactions as well as their facial
recognition patterns and to actually be
able to diagnose a case of stroke in a
timely manner during the surgery during
the procedure
if you're able to do that finish quickly
whatever you're doing and you probably
will be able to treat that patient who's
in the hospital to
begin with
so that's a huge problem and we
quantified it
in terms of suffering first of all in
terms of
the burden to the patient the families
the cause and the fact that there
are no solutions to that problem and i
think we have something running that's
uh very promising and we're already
testing it so
um that's one example we've got uh quite
a few more
each year we're running tens of projects
out of which
a few make it all the way to the end
and
are
first of all composed of a good team
because the team is the number one
component of any any good invention
right any good company and then the the
the problem with the solution makes
sense and have a uh hold a promise to a
worldwide a global solution
and so every year we have a few of those
that that we're trying to
build up here
and so then what happens right after
that step so after after you've been
working with them you're presenting them
what what actually happens from that
moment forward
all right so that's that's an
interesting question because it really
it really changes between one
uh inventor to the other some
might want to take
um
and become
founders right and that's that
or nurse wanted to be part of an
invention process like that and
it's a startup
for something that's
financially viable and so on
direct
founders
will be very glad if that happens
even those are
good ceos in some
engineering
to drive these things forward
that's right these are
full-time
uh hospital employees
doctors nurses technicians and so on
they will want to
to maintain their full-time job they
will become consultants and
you know
innovation hubs in israel
or
be driven by someone else a ceo so
collaboration is really an important
part of this process
and and what is it
how are the physicians and clinicians
receptive to these new innovations are
they you know excited about their
presentations are they excited about the
new opportunities they're presenting do
they maybe feel threatened by
by the by you know new standards and new
ways of doing things
oh well
well uh
here's the thing they're they're used to
presenting most of these i mean at least
the physicians but
they're they're they live in an academic
environment they know how to present
medical research
but when it comes to to a a pitch or a
new startup which is what we teach them
to do
we actually work on a logo and a
name and they have to make a case
what they're presenting is not just an
academic discussion or or a poster or a
research they've worked on this is
his position
and you know
but this
they've actually given pitch to a crowd
and the
crowd um in that event but in general
because they'll meet a lot of investors
and business people and so on
it's a different experience and it's in
fact it's one of the things that we want
to teach and we want these folks to
experience the world of entrepreneurship
they are drawn to that
and we give them the opportunity to try
it for for real so yes they're excited
they're they're outside of their comfort
zone they sometimes start with a
terrible pitch a good scientific
description of the medical field but
does not speak to the crowd right it
makes no sense to someone who is not a
physician or even in that specific field
of expertise and we'll you know pull
them back and say listen we no one
understands what you're let's start with
pictures let's be more you know a little
bit more explanatory let's be more uh
obvious and
make us
understand why this is important uh
don't use scientific terms but use
layman language and and so on and so
forth and build a story so we work on
the politician right so the
the presentation itself is a skill you
know it's interesting it's fun
it's good to learn but the real exciting
part is the fact that we understand we
help them
translate their medical needs into a
language that someone can act identify
with and potentially solve um and that
and that's exactly the bridge that we're
trying to work on
so leo take me back a little bit to your
childhood again and you know you meant
you started by sharing your fascination
with you know the being a doctor and
creating that fake heart but but what
really sparks your curiosity even about
this segment so where does the
fascination really come from
it is it's unbelievable
with people
brilliant doctors or or nurses
pt we have all sorts but these
real clinicians
who understand their field very well
and are experts in their field and have
the will
and the desire to change the world i
mean people use that phrase but this is
these are the folks who can actually
change it because
they are cutting edge in their field of
expertise right um and when they come in
with with a dream
most of these are failures right i'm
sorry to say it we don't judge them as
failures uh but we we
realized that this is a
non-viable need in terms of a financial
you know market size it's just the way
it is
can
if you can't build a a running company
then you won't
build solutions it's just that's the
reality uh there
um or it's already out there and they
didn't know that the their patents that
uh blocked
that exists out there that's kind of
competing in a way that you know it's
not worth walking that path or it's just
too difficult
but uh but the process of looking at
these people coming in um with ideas
with needs and actually
trying to make it happen
it's the best reality tv show that uh
that i've ever seen and it's live for us
i love it and when they actually succeed
and when they actually make it happen
and they stand in front of a crowd with
with a with a compelling story right and
they are the experts to actually tell it
they have the empathy to the patients
more than anyone else they've seen it
once and again
um and they've gone through the process
with us and they actually came out from
the other way with a a mock-up or a
prototype of a solution
i mean that's just uh it's mind-blowing
and it's exciting every time
and i think that's what i'm drawn to um
it doesn't make sense in other ways it
makes more sense to actually
work only on the on the private practice
let me let me tell you but it's just
it's larger than life and so that's what
i'm drawn to
i love it very very cool
and you also answered obviously my
question about your your inspiration
today but what are three words that you
would use to describe yourself
three words that i used to describe
myself
um
i'm critical
uh
i guess i'm full of excitement and
motivation
and i always
i always listen to my wife
is that a word
i'll take i'll take it as a word i'll
i'll definitely take it as a word leo
there you go thank you very very much
for the time and energy i really
appreciate it this was a lot of fun and
thank you for all the amazing work that
you're doing
and i can't wait to follow the journey
and and and to meet some of these
amazing companies and thank you for
everything and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you michael it's been a pleasure
and i i'm an admirer of your of the
series of people that you interview
keep up the great work and and thank you
very much for having me